У Молдові нині гаряче.
Уряд Додона має піти у відставку за некомпетентність, переслідування людей, покривання корупційних схем.
Ми вимагаємо відставки уряду та позачергових парламентських виборів!
Безпрецедентні порушення, яких не було на жодній виборчій кампанії за всі роки незалежності.
Я не закликаю нікого виходити на вулиці. Нам не потрібна дестабілізація. Ситуація і так непроста.
На президентських виборах Майя Санду перемогла Ігоря Додона, якого багато хто вважає проросійським.
Але чинна влада намагається тепер обмежити її майбутні повноваження.
Поки політикиня заявляє про необхідність виведення російських військ з Придністров'я,
парламент Молдови виводить з-під контролю президента Службу інформації й безпеки - головну розвідслужбу країни.
Також парламентарі посилили статус російської мови та повернули в ефір російські телепрограми.
А також посилили юридичний статус Гагаузької автономії, що, на думку опозиції, загрожує федералізацією.
Депутати від опозиції намагалися будь-якою ціною не допустити затвердження цих та інших суперечливих ініціатив.
Мовні закони - реверанс парламентської більшості у бік російськомовних виборців та Москви, каже медіаексперт Дмитро Цира.
І додає, що пропагандистський контент з Росії ще більше розділяє і без того роз'єднане суспільство.
Для партії соціалістів це просто політичний хід.
Їхня стратегія заснована на геополітиці, і цим вони надсилають своїм виборцям меседж про захист прав російськомовних.
Хоча я не бачу проблем у Молдові з російською.
Соціалісти, які на виборах підтримали Додона, пояснюють нагальність мовних законів інтересами свободи слова.
Я прихильник того, щоб дати людям освіту, аби вони могли відрізнити фейкньюз від правди самостійно.
Тоді все буде добре. А робити їх зашореними - дивіться туди й не дивіться туди - не можна!
Обмеження повноважень Санду щодо спецслужб пояснюють тим, що вони не можуть підпорядковуватися людині з подвійним громадянством.
Румунський паспорт Санду став причиною закидів, що начебто вона прихильниця ідея об'єднання Молдови з Румунією.
Хоча сама політикиня неодноразово це спростовувала. Ось що кажуть її соратники.
Це примітивні хлопці з менталітетом провінційних бандюків, які вважають,
що таким чином зможуть реабілітуватися в очах виборців, помститися Майї, піти на вибори й отримати контрольний пакет у наступному парламенті.
Майя Санду закликала своїх прихильників на масову акцію протесту в Кишиневі найближчої неділі.
А її партія вже оскаржила в Конституційному суді обмеження повноважень майбутньої президентки.
Санду запевнила, що будуватиме відносини з усіма країнами.
Її попередник Додон, який називав Крим російським, відвернув від себе і Київ, і Бухарест, і ЄС.
Ми побудуємо справжній баланс у зовнішній політиці, виходячи з національних інтересів Молдови.
І прагматичний діалог з усіма країнами, включно з Румунією, Україною, європейськими країнами, Росією та США.
Інавгуація президентки призначена на 24 грудня.
У Європі вважають, що молдовські виборці, обираючи між Додоном і Санду, надіслали сигнал, що вони хочуть розпрощатися зі старими традиціями.
Вперше південно-східні сусіди України обирають президентом жінку.
Їй вірять, що вона не зростеться з корупцією.
Однак перед Санду стоїть великий виклик - згуртувати країну з населенням 3,5 мільйони, яку розкололи політики і дезінформація.